(guitar music)
- Yo.
- Wassup.
- Game of Thrones though dog.
- No, you all caught up?
- Bro, I totally
binged watched that
whole thing last night dog!
- So it's cold-blooded
up in Westeros, dog!
- They killed my (beep) Ned!
- Ned Starks!
Dum dum dum dum da da da dum.
You ain't seen that
one comin' did ya?
- Oh (beep) hell no.
- Uh uh.
- Oh my God.
- I mean my man was
just there, right?
And he's talkin' 'bout,
he got down there
on the thing like blip.
- Shing!
- And then I was like,
pssh, I ain't worried,
they ain't gonna kill
my boy Ned Starks.
- Slip.
- And then plop.
I was like ahhh!
- Yo I told you they
cold-blooded up in there.
- And then I was
like, but that's okay
because I still got
my (beep) Khal Drogo.
- Oh big Dave Navarro?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Big Dave Navarro.
- Big Dave...
(guitar)
(screams)
- Yeah, that dude picked
up some molten gold,
poured it on (beep) heads!
(screams)
- I wanna sleep with my sister.
- Yo.
- And then he killed him, right.
I mean he big like
Hercules and everything.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, you can't kill
Khal Drogos with a papercut!
- An infected
scratch up on there?
- An infected scratch!
- But he got straight
(simultaneous) killed!
- Oh, but you know who
my favorite character is?
- Who's that dog,
who's that dog?
- Psst, Khaleesis.
- Khaleesi.
- You know I be likin'
some Khaleesis doy.
- But what about Khaleesis
straight up with them dragons?
Khaleesis with them dragons.
- Khaleesis with them dragons.
- And Khaleesi's all like this.
And then we talkin' 'bout
- [Peele] Dragons be like.
(screeches)
(Key screeches)
(Peele screeches)
(roars)
- Just straight roastin' goats!
- Yo!
- Oh my God!
- Yeah, and that's
when they start
killin' characters
left and right dog!
- At the wedding?
- Yo at the wedding!
- Robb Starks.
- What.
- His wife.
- They got his mom.
- Yo!
(simultaneous) Kilt,
kilt, kilt, kilt.
- That was a four for one dog.
- Four for one up there dog.
- That's a straight
four for one.
- Four for one up in there.
- What about when they
got Wildlings girl?
Talkin' about...
You know nothing Jon Snow.
(simultaneous) Kilt!
- What about the Hound though?
- (Peele) Yo, pssht the
Hound talkin' about...
- (Key) Ahhh! I'm
fallin' down the hill!
- Click!
(Key screams)
- Kill me, you gotta kill me!
- No!
(simultaneous) Kilt!
- Slowly, by omission.
- Be gone.
- Yo but what about my
man Taiwan Lannisters?
- Taiwan Lannisters.
- But Taiwan Lannisters though.
- Yo my man talkin' about
(grunts) I'm takin' a (beep).
- He said (squeals)
- Unh.
(simultaneous) Kilt!
- By his own son.
- What?
- Dadinkles.
(gasp)
- Dadinkles yo.
- Dadinkles.
(simultaneous) Dadinkles!
- Dadinkles is my jam.
- Can't nobody kill Dadinkles!
- Dadinkles is my jam, my jelly,
my peanut butter,
and my peanuts.
- Dinkles
- Dadinkles.
- Dinkles though!
(simultaneous)
Dinkles is my (beep)
(yelling)
(choral music)